federal civil rights lawyers are on the
ground in minneapolis this morning as
part of a sweeping new
investigation into the city's police
department
u.s attorney general merrick garland
says the department of justice is
looking into whether there's a larger
pattern
of discrimination and excessive use of
force
far beyond the george floyd case jeff
pigues is in minneapolis jeff what can
you tell us about this investigation
well it's really anthony going to put a
focus a
microscope on the minneapolis pd and the
third precinct here behind me or what's
left of it
this is where derek shoving once worked
and during the protest it was torched
we undertake this task with
determination
and urgency knowing that change
cannot wait the u.s attorney general
says the probe will look into whether
the minneapolis police department
engages in
unlawful policing including
discrimination it will include a
comprehensive review
of the minneapolis police department's
policies
training supervision and use of force
investigations
after george floyd's death vandals
torched the third precinct where derek
chovin worked
minneapolis police chief madaria
arredondo acknowledged that precinct had
a reputation during an interview last
year
what kind of reputation does the third
precinct have
i've heard that the third precinct has
an attitude
the minneapolis police department has
long been known to be
troubled christie lopez led the doj
investigation into the ferguson police
department
after the deadly police shooting of
michael brown in 2014.
incidents like george floyd's killing
and officers like derek shovin don't
exist in a vacuum
they are allowed to persist
because the culture supports that or
allows that
pattern or practice investigations of
police departments
were largely put on hold during the
trump administration
it conducted just one compared to the 25
during the two terms of the obama
administration
it makes me very very happy george
floyd's younger sister
bridget hopes meaningful police reform
will be part of her brother's legacy
we know that we will never get him back
that's the sad part about it
but we have rejoiced in the end
because things are going to be put in
position to change
this federal pattern or practice
investigation could take a year or
longer
to complete meanwhile there is renewed
pressure on lawmakers around the country
to
come to a deal on police reform after
chauvin's conviction
tony jeff thank you very much